[Musique]
où
l'ouragan se déchaînaient ce soir là sur
la lande un vin aigre qui venait du
large jetait son haleine glacée sur la
terre couverte d'une herbe rase
seul l'état mary pliait sous la bise en
geignant comme amant père à quelques
pieds de la falaise la mer à marée haute
butait à grands coups de bélier sur les
rochers noirs qui marquait l'entrée
d'une plage de sable fin comme drapé
dans le velours d'une ailes de chauve
souris une ombre frêle avancer
péniblement sur la grève presque celle
d'un enfant
yann s'en aller chercher fortune
ailleurs passant de ferme en ferme pour
demander sa maigre pitance
en échange de quelques menus services la
claque puissante du vent s'abattait sur
unis et ils luttaient il se courber pour
n'être pas renverser 20 fois le souffle
coupé par aton millions plus violent il
failli revenir sur ses pas
non il n'allait pas renoncer parce que
la nuit se faisaient de plus en plus
menaçante
l'imprimante un frisson qu'il s'empressa
de mettre sur le compte de la fraîcheur
de cette soirée d'hiver
yann poursuivi ça
afin de ne pas laisser mille pensées
effrayante envahir son esprit tourmenté
il tenta de fixer son attention sur
quelque chose de rassurant de familier
d'un geste nerveux il chercha dans la
poche de sa houppelande le coquillage
dont il ne se séparait jamais il se mit
à le serrer de toutes ses forces puis
joie pendant quelques instants avec le
bouton qui fermait son ami allons quand
on a 16 ans on n'est plus un enfant et
ont fait fi des légendes qui hantent
cette terre d'eau et de sel que le vent
harcèle et ronge sans repos il faut
tellement peu pour que naisse une
légende une touffe d'herbe qui roule sur
le sable un froissement d'elle dans la
pénombre les yeux d'un animal furtif qui
lui centre de brison ici on dit que la
lande est traîtresse concié gare
facilement les miss et yann c'est bien
pour l'avoir parcouru tant de fois sous
le soleil
elle ouvre sur une falaise haute comme
une cathédrale
on dit aussi que les soirs de grand vent
un étrange cavaliers drapée de noir dont
nul n'a jamais vu le visage traverse la
plage en poussant des cris d'un an
il vient de la mer monté sur un cheval
noir dont les yeux est un sel comme deux
brasiers
alors les gens du pays se terrent chez
eux se serre autour de l'âtre parle plus
haut comme pour couvrir les cris qui
monte de la plage
ces soirs là personne ne sort depuis la
nuit des temps les gens d'ici redoutent
de rencontrer le cavalier qui vient de
la mer
il annonce le malheur
yann sentait tous ces souvenirs qu'il
croyait enfoui au fond de sa mémoire
l'envahir peu à peu ils avaient
l'impression d'une sorte de tension
quasi insupportable emplissait
l'atmosphère et à ce sentiment de
malaise succède à bientôt
l'intuition d'une présence quelqu'un il
en était persuadé se cachait dans les
ténèbres
là tout près comme le bruit d'une
respiration haletante celle de quelques
monstres qui aurait fait une longue
course pour venir à la rencontre de
l'enfant
yann senti la terreur l'envahir et il
s'entendit répétaient les lèvres glace
et que c'était le vent le vent seul qui
fatigués de souffler avec tant de fureur
et de haine venait mourir sur la lande
une fois encore il murmura s'élevant ce
n'est que le vent malgré le tumulte de
la tempête
le garçon cru soudain distingué comme un
bruit de pas retenu un inconnu avançait
lentement dans la nuit yann tandis
l'oreille il avait l'impression que
c'était elle est éclatée qu'elle ne
résisterait pas une seconde de plus
quelqu'un dans l'obscurité le guettait
suivaient chacun de ses mouvements
il écoutait un instant encore plus rien
il scrutait les ténèbres regarda autour
de lui le coeur battant à tout rompre le
vague à montserrat les pans de sa cape
en remontant le col comme pour se
protéger et décida de revenir sur ses
pas il allait regagner la ferme dont il
distingue est encore la pâle lueur dans
le lointain et reprenait sa marche le
lendemain alors yann s'aperçut avec
effroi que la mère atteignait déjà les
premiers rocher qui borde la plage la
marée avait recouvert la bande de sable
qui l'avait empruntée pour venir jusque
là il était trop tard pour reculer il
détourna son regard il posa sur la
falaise de granit qui surplombait la
grève comme une muraille à prenable il
savait bien qu'il lui était impossible
d'escaladé cette masse rocheuse en
pleine nuit la pluie dévalait la falaise
écoulé sur les rochers comme un torrent
de larmes ya une sourde angoisse
tenaillait ce mythe en devoir de
poursuivre sa lente progression qu'il en
était sûr quelqu'un se cacher dans les
ténèbres
à un moment il se dit que s'il voyait
quelque chose n'importe quoi cela leur
assurerait presque mais il avait beau
fouiller la plage du regard il ne voyait
rien rien sinon la masse de la falaise
les rochers plus sombre qui se devine
est dans l'obscurité et la vaste étendue
de sable nu là bas l'écumé des vagues la
nuit cachets des yeux qu'il ne pouvait
distinguer des mains prêtes à la paix
les battements de son coeur résonnaient
dans sa poitrine avec une netteté
surprenant
tan tan tan son coeur battait si fort
qu'il lui était impossible de respirer
de parler ou d'appeler soudain un cri
vrille à la nuit épaisse couvrir le
bruit des vagues contre les brisants
yann s'arrêta interdit à nouveau le cri
déchire à la nuit jaillit de la mer pour
s'envoler on appelle des chirons
l'enfant senti son sang se figer tandis
que sa bouche se sécher et qu'une sueur
de glace ruisselet dans son dos en un
geste désespéré il tenta en vain
d'avancé l'oreille aux aguets mais ils
n'entendent plus que la plainte
familière des cornes de brume un long
gémissements comme sortie de la gueule
de quelque animal fabuleux cacher
derrière le rideau impénétrable de la
nuit
[Musique]
yann resta là comme pétrifiés incapable
de faire le moindre geste tandis que
venait toujours du rivage
l'immense clameur qui lui glaçait le
sang
il trouva enfin la force de faire
quelques pas et se blottit derrière un
rocher une masse sombre sortie de la mer
traverser la plage alors l'angoissent
qui ronge les nerfs du garçon se fit
erreur poignante
c'était bien un cavalier tout de noir
vêtu montant un coursier couleurs de
nuit qui venait de surgir des flots il
ya un an avait la certitude
bien qu'il ne plus distinguer avec
netteté la silhouette qui se déplaçait
sur la plage et il crut bientôt voir
scintiller les yeux du cheval comme une
gerbe des toiles combien de temps reste
at il ainsi immobile à suivre des yeux
l'étrange va et vient qui se déroulait
de la plage de la falaise jamais dessus
le dira pas plus qu'il ne sût dire
comment peu à peu sa terreur se changea
en une sorte de fascination comme poussé
par une force à contrôler yann quitta sa
cachette et fit quelques pas en avant il
avait l'impression de n'être plus maître
de lui même était il réellement sur
cette plage faisait t-il un rêve et il
s'aperçut qu'il s'en allait à la
rencontre du cavalier qui venait de la
mer
celui dont il avait tant et tant entendu
parler et dont nul jamais n'avait vu le
visage l'homme approchait et son cri de
temps en temps éclataient dans la nuit
le galop de son cheval martelait le
sable en à grône mansur plus près encore
plus prêt bientôt l'étrange équipage
arrive assure yann qui fixe à la tête du
cavalier elle lui parut singulièrement
2 comme coiffé d'une sorte de capuche
noire écarquillant les yeux il distingua
enfin une pâleur irait elle chercha
avidement quelques traits humains
soudain yann senti ses cheveux se
dresser sous son bonnet essayé en vain
de résister au vertige qui l'envahissait
et pousse un hurlement de terreur avant
de se laisser tomber sur le sable la
tête qui se tournaient vers lui n'avait
pas de visage
le cheval se cabra puis s'arrête à m le
cavalier mis pied à terre et l'on
entendit bientôt plus que le crissement
du sable sous ses pas pesant lancinant
menaçant une phase livide se penche
enfin sur le garçon il la vit grossir
démesurément tandis qu'elle se
rapprochait de son propre visage elle
était lisse sans yeux c'en est sans
bouche quelques algues ruisselante d'eau
s'y agrippent est encore
bientôt elle semble occuper tout
l'espace toute la place
la nuit tout entier en un geste
d'ultimes défense yann se couvrit les
yeux de ses mains glacées
un rire amer éclata dans la nuit alors
le garçon se sentit sombrer dans un
gouffre sans fond quand yann rault
ouvrit les yeux déjà le jour naissait la
mère s'était retirée la plage était
déserte
il essaya de se lever mais ils se
sentent ici faible que ses genoux se
mirent à trembler il ne pouvait faire un
geste
une sourde angoisse les treigny qui
passerait jamais sur la plage en ce
matin d'hiver au loin par delà les dunes
il distinguer les mâts des chalutiers
qui attendaient la marée haute pour
quitter le port les pêcheurs devaient
s'activer aux préparatifs il les
imaginait sur le quai raccommodant leurs
filets il essaya d'appeler au secours
mais n'entendit pour toute réponse que
l'écho de sa voix sur la falaise et le
crime au coeur des mouettes désespéré
yann se blottit dans sa houppelande et
peu à peu il sentit son corps se
réchauffer nantes alors
un vague soupçon envahi son esprit
tourmenté avec il réellement vu un homme
sans visage avait t-il rencontrer le
cavalier qui terrorisait paysans et
pêcheurs dans ce pays du bout du monde
quant à vieux matelots le découvrit
enfin yann voulu lui conter la nuit
d'épouvanté qu'il avait vécu mais il
sentit une immense lassitude l'envahir
il tenta encore quelques mots puis
renonce à près de lui
[Musique]
des empreintes de sabots de cheval s'en
allait vers la mer
depuis personne n'a revu le cavalier ni
sa mystérieuse monture peut-être parce
que personne ne s'est attardé sur la
plage les nuits de grands vents si vous
passez dans mon village
vous remarquerez peut-être un vieil
homme qui prend le soleil devant sa
petite maison de granit
c'est yann à moins que ce ne soit son
fils où le fils de son fils où cette
histoire et sciences yens demandez lui
de vous parler du cavalier qui venait de
la mer
il ne se fera pas trop prier et
lorsqu'il aura terminé
si quelqu'un vous dit que yann avait
tout simplement rêver ou qu'il avait
tout au plus rencontré quelques
contrebandiers au visage masqué
profitant de la marée haute pour faire
son commerce
s'il vous dit que le cavalier poucet de
grands cris pour terroriser paysan et
pêcheur et n'être pas déranger ne le
croyez surtout pas aller plutôt sur la
plage
vous y verrez peut-être à marée basse
des empreintes de sabots qui s'enfonce
dans les flots